chaque année 160 mille enfants dans
notre pays sont victimes de violences
sexuelles nous devons les trouver pour
les protéger depuis deux mois la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
les violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants appelle les victimes à parler
6000 ont déjà témoigné il y a près de
quarante ans ces témoignages étaient
difficiles à entendre
j'ai très délicat d'aborder le problème
de l'inceste mais il est de notre devoir
de vous en parler car le phénomène n'est
pas isolé en france ne s'agit pas de
vous montrer des témoignages je ne serai
pas pudique mais là encore d'essayer de
comprendre il ya deux mots évidemment
qu'ils retiennent mon attention le
premier c'est comprendre
le second c'est pudique où impudique
comprendre commence par voir tant que
l'humain n'a pas dans sa conscience la
perception du réel tel qu'il est vécu
par l'enfant alors comprendre n'est pas
possible d'après edward durant les
victimes disent juste le réel et oblige
la société à ouvrir les yeux en 1984 des
victimes brise l'omerta et ose parler à
la télévision est l'une d'entre elles
anne-marie par les mêmes à visage
découvert donc il ya un changement cette
parole n'est plus impudique elle produit
de la conscience collective
mon père a commencé à nous mettre les
autres enfants aubin et c'est comme ça
que ça a commencé donc il nous a touchés
moi personnellement je mets l'âge 8 en 8
ans de mahé flore et à ce moment là
puis ça a continué il n'a jamais eu de
rapports sexuels avec moi mais tout le
reste presque j'y suis passé donc
jusqu'à mes 18 ans effleuré pas de
rapport sexuel elle dit le réel presque
en deçà de l'horreur effectivement
éprouvé il faut les mots de la loi pour
dire ce que suggèrent les mots qu à
l'emploi c'est à dire une agression
sexuelle incestueuse
répété pendant 10 1 il fallait que ces
femmes et aussi ses hommes nous disent
et nous oblige à prendre position
prendre position c'est ce qui quarante
ans plus tard et demandé à la société
ansamble sortant du silence être du côté
de l'agresseur ou du côté des victimes
d'un témoignage impudique d'une
tentative de comprendre nous sommes
passés à l'obligation d'écouter devoir
est de protéger les victimes
[Musique]